I might as well just have called this
one absent daddy issues the show so
overdue Doctor Who review it's finally
flowing smoothly off my tongue that
sounded really dirty
I should retake that and I won't so I'm
up to this episode and this one I was
both not looking forward to but also
really curious about because I am on
record more than a few places I'm not
really liking this episode very much and
like to be fair I think in some ways my
historical distaste for this episode is
amplified possibly unfairly by how much
other people seem to really love it
there's something inherently frustrating
about not liking something and not
understanding why no one else around you
sees the faults in it I'd like to think
up a little more fair than I used to be
though and I haven't rewatch this
episode in ages and when I say ages I
mean I haven't rewashed it since I
myself became a father so I think if
this thing was ever gonna have a shot at
hitting me better than they had up to
this point this was gonna be it so
having now watched it it is better than
I have given it credit for in the past
particularly in regards to the emotional
element of it Pete Tyler is actually a
really great character both in and of
himself but also especially in his
interactions with rose particularly they
are really touching and heartfelt and I
like how intelligent he is I like his
ability to work things out and figure
out what's going on not because he's a
genius but because he can he's paying
attention and putting his mind to
a problem and it never feels like they
are overstating his ability to figure
things out and it feels like it plays
fair with that element and his decision
to go in front of that car is well
played his recognition of what the
doctor was trying to spare her from but
that he has to do because he's her
father as much as he may want to protect
her from all the hazards of the world
sometimes you know he can't he sometimes
he has to protect her from herself you
know it's it's well played in it's nice
and it's very touching that doesn't mean
I now like this episode because overall
I still don't so I wanted to acknowledge
that up front that the I do get that
element and I get that if that
particular element hits you hard enough
it can override other issues with the
story I get that I have thing I am you
know episodes of Doctor Who books movies
in general that will have something in
them that I like so much that it either
renders me incapable of noticing the
other faults or I am more forgiving of
them that's since I can't I can't with
this I think my biggest frustration is
the Reapers
so those are the monsters of this thing
and I
I kind of hate the way in which this
episode tries to do broken time I hate
these things I think they're dumb I
think they look stupid I think the idea
is very poorly delved into I don't think
that they add anything I think they
actively detract I think it would have
been so much better I mean you still you
do the paradox you do time is broken you
do things are coming apart people are
vanishing the world outside is you know
fading away maybe but to literally
weaponize that into monsters is I'm
sorry
it's dumb it's dumb and it just it it
actively detracts because instead of
this potentially what we could have had
slow creeping sense of things being
wrong little things being off like the
phone call or you know boy there aren't
many people huh where is everybody and
you know the doctor coming to that
realization and you know maybe even just
like one shot if they look down the
street and at a certain point down the
street there's nothing like literally
nothing there's a void and realizing
that that's encroaching in on them
because they are effectively the center
of the paradox and everything is closing
in on them I feel like that would have
been a much more effective way to give
us the ticking clock that was necessary
to force the hand and keep things moving
forward without literally having
freaking time monsters I really hate
these things and it doesn't help that I
don't even I can't even give it the
benefit where I was like oh well it's a
kind of original idea well no it's the
friggin Langille ears from the Stephen
King miniseries and they weren't very
good there either I know they're not
literally the same thing but I can't see
this and not think of that and it didn't
work there either but at least when I
saw that it was an original idea that
didn't work now it's a derivative idea
that still doesn't work so I mean most
of my problems with this episode keep
coming back to them I don't like the
need to have a monster because I feel
like every time we cut away from the
emotional impact of you know Pete
realizing what's going on in the fact
that he's not alive and Rose trying very
hard to paint a rosy picture for him and
lying to him about what she means to him
in the future every time we cut away
from that to have a monster outside the
judge go for it saps the moments it
kills it dead I really I hate these
friggin things and they're all over the
episode like as soon as the paradox
starts we get our first like POV with
red Wibbly vision of these things and I
immediately groaned I can't help but
groan because they don't help the story
literally the only thing that they do
that just off the top of my head cuz I
didn't sit down and think a lot long and
hard about this before recording this
video the only I can't think of off the
top of my head is how you remove the
doctor specifically from the
circumstances they do accomplish that
but I'd like to think that the writers
of Doctor Who are more clever than I am
and give it a little bit more time than
you know
ten minutes after having finished an
episode having watched it that they
would be able to come up with a better
idea in the fact that I can't think of
how they would do that doesn't mean that
there was no other way to do it than to
have a monster eat him I'm trying dial
it back because I feel like right now it
sounds like am i hating on this episode
for more that's worth because like I
said this is overall actually you know I
said it was better than I remember I'm
not sure the episode is better than I
remember it what is good about the
episode is stronger than I remember it
but the things that don't work really
don't work and there were something that
my mind had exaggerated like my memory
of Rose getting handed the baby was that
it happened much more slowly my memory
of that was much more you see you know
peace starts to hand her the baby and
she's like oh and the baby's there it's
like and she had been lecture but doctor
don't touch the baby and you know
example fine you know how it's gonna
make situation there and already worse
and my memory was that that moment was
more dragged out heard being handed the
baby and I and I hated my memory version
of that because I'm like how are you
just sitting there letting him hand you
this baby um in in reality played much
faster I kinda wish they hadn't done a
cutaway to the doctor going Rose know
and starting to run because that did
make it feel like a longer moment that
it actually was so there are things like
that where I think it's healthy for me
to come back every watch these and
realize oh that thing that I thought was
like a real big issue or at least was a
hang-up for me my memory isn't actually
accurate on that so I mean it's nice to
realize that in some ways it doesn't
have all of the faults that I have
thought that I have tended to think that
it has but those friggin monsters man I
just it's it especially for a show that
has a tendency to especially in the
early you know series to get hung up on
the monster of the week and this
honestly this came up last episode that
I reviewed with the long game because
the jagrafess doesn't help either
he's also distracting there's just this
insertion of a monster because there's
like a presumption that we have to have
a monster every story and I've now had
two stories in a row where two an
increasing degree the monsters not only
don't help I think the story would have
been actively better without them so
yeah it's just it's frustrating because
I feel like I have a better recognition
of what does work here and I think
Billie Piper gives a great performance
in sort of showing wanting to find that
connection with the father that she's
never known and I think she plays that
well Peter I already mentioned does
great work and the doctor does good with
his bits he's much more background here
than he often is but he's still good and
the performances overall are fine it's
just these freaking things
I'm so glad they've never come back I've
seen people like on occasion as
paradoxes have come up with other
stories of Zaku they're like I wonder
why the Reapers don't show up because
it's a paradox and the supposed to
sterilize the would like I don't care
what the narrative explanation is for
them not showing up I'm so glad these
things I've never shown up again god I
hate them so that'll wrap up my coverage
of Father's Day what are your thoughts
on it whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
I know historically have been on the
minority side in terms of my opinion of
this episode
I don't know if my ranting this angrily
explains it better or just makes me look
like more of a jackass about it I don't
know let me know um so there's a whole
bunch of links down there like buttons
and stuff and they take you places this
oh wait - the patreon plus a whole bunch
of other stuff check it out if you feel
like it and remember folks regardless of
whether you look at that stuff or not
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]